DELIVER A SINGLE UNIT OF HEAVY
WEAPONRY TO KYIV DESPITE HAVING
APPROVED IT IN APRIL.
>> IN THE VIEWS OF THE UKRAINIAN
GOVERNMENT, THE GERMANS HAVE
BEEN A LOT OF TALK.
>> Translator: PUTIN MUST NOT
WIN HIS WAR, AND I AM CONVINCED
HE WILL NOT WIN.
>> AND NOT ENOUGH ACTION.
>> THIS WEEK, PRESIDENT
VOLODYMYR ZELENSKYY ISSUED A
RARE PUBLIC REBUKE OF GERMAN
CHANCELLOR OLAF SCHOLZ, SAYING
THIS ONE TO ONE GERMAN NEWS
OUTLET.
>> Translator: WE NEED THE
CHANCELLOR TO GIVE US CERTAINLY
EHE WILL SUPPORT UKRAINE.
THEY MUST CHOOSE NOT TO DO A
BALANCING ACT BETWEEN UKRAINE
AND THE RUSSIAN FEDERATION.
>> WHILE IT'S TRUE SHOLTS USES
THE RIGHT WORDS, CALLING THIS A
TURNING POINT IN THE HISTORY OF
GERMAN FOREIGN POLICY, A TERM
NOT USED LIGHTLY, SOME CRITICS
FEEL IT'S DIFFERENT WHEN IT
COMES TO GERMAN CHANCELLOR'S
DEEDS.
ONE WROTE, THE CHANCELLOR,
DESPITE HIS STRONG TALK AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE WAR, HAS CHOSEN
EFFECTIVELY TO DO NOTHING.
HIS INDECISIVENESS IS MORE THAN
A POLITICAL FAILURE.
IT AMOUNTS TO A DANGEROUS
WEAKENING OF THE RESOLVE OF
THOSE WHO OPPOSE RUSSIA'S WAR,
CLEARING THE WAY FOR MORE
BRUTALITY AND VIOLENCE.
SO CRITICS ARGUE, AS RUSSIANS
STOMP VIOLENTLY ACROSS UKRAINE,
GERMANY HAS BEEN DRAGGING ITS
BOOTS.
GERMANY'S ECONOMIC MIGHT AS THE
EUROPEAN UNION'S BIGGEST ECONOMY
MAKES IT A CRITICAL PLAYER HERE.
BUT INSTEAD OF OUTRIGHT BANNING
ALL OIL AND GAS IMPORTS FROM
RUSSIA, GERMANY HAS OPTED TO,
QUOTE, PHASE OUT THOSE
SHIPMENTS, CONTINUING A REVENUE
STREAM WHICH SOME CRITICS SAY
HELPS FUND RUSSIAN WAR EFFORTS.
AND WHILE GERMANY REACTED
QUICKLY, VOWING TO SEND
DESPERATELY NEEDED TANKS AND
ANTI-AIRCRAFT SYSTEMS TO THE
UKRAINIAN FRONT LINES, THE
GOVERNMENT LATER BACK PEDALED,
DECLARING GERMANY NEEDED TO KEEP
THE WEAPONRY, AND THAT ANYWAY,
UKRAINIAN SOLDIERS WERE NOT
SUFFICIENTLY TRAINED TO HANDLE
SUCH ADVANCED TECHNOLOGY.
THAT'S A CRITICISM QUICKLY
REJECTED BY ZELENSKYY WHEN I SAT
DOWN WITH HIM IN APRIL.
>> I HAVE HEARD MANY TIMES FROM
CERTAIN STATES THAT DID NOT WANT
TO GIVE US WEAPONS QUICKLY
BECAUSE OUR SOLDIERS ARE NOT
READY FROM A TECHNICAL
STANDPOINT TO USE THEM.
BUT INSTRUCTORS OF SUCH
EQUIPMENT, OUR INSTRUCTORS, WILL
GET OUR TROOPS READY TO FIGHT IN
THEM.
>> WHEN PRESSED EARLIER THIS
MONTHS, SCHULTZ EVEN MADE THE
BUZAUR AND FALSE CLAIM THAT,
QUOTE, NOBODY SUPPLIES ON A
SIMILAR SCALE AS GERMANY DOES,
UNQUOTE.
WHICH IS NOT TRUE IN ANY WAY.
NOT IN TOTAL DOLLARS, NOT IN
PERCENTAGES.
AND IN THE RUN-UP TO RUSSIA'S
INVASION, SCHULTZ REBUFFED
INTERNATIONAL PRESSURE TO COMMIT
TO ENDING THE NORD STREAM 2
PIPELINE, A MASSIVE PROJECT THAT
WOULD FUNNEL LUCRATIVE GAS FROM
RUSSIA TO GERMANY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID THAT THE
PIPELINE WOULD NOT HAPPEN IF
RUSSIA INVADES.
YOU WON'T SAY THAT.
HOW WOULD PRESIDENT BIDEN STOP
THE PIPELINE, JUST BY IMPOSING
SEVERE SANCTIONS?
AND WHY WON'T YOU EXPLICITLY SAY
RUSSIA, IF YOU INVADE UKRAINE,
WE'RE CANCELING THE PIPELINE?
>> WE'RE DOING MUCH MORE AS ONE
STEP.
AND ALL THE STEPS WE WILL TAKE,
WE WILL DO TOGETHER, AS THE
PRESIDENT SAID.
WE'RE PREPARING FOR THAT, AND
YOU CAN UNDERSTAND AND BE
ABSOLUTELY SURE THAT GERMANY
WILL BE TOGETHER WITH ALL OF ITS
ALLIES AND ESPECIALLY THE UNITED
STATES.
>> UNDER SCRUTINY FROM THE U.S.
AND OTHER NATO ALLIES, SCHULTZ
DID EVENTUALLY SUSPEND THAT
PROJECT.
AND HE HAS TAKEN OTHER STEPS TO
SUPPORT UKRAINE'S EFFORTS.
SUCH AS A PLEDGE TO DELIVER TWO
MAJOR WEAPONS TO ITS ARMY, AN
AIR DEFENSE SYSTEM AND A
TRACKING RADAR.
IN ADDITION TO HUMANITARIAN AND
MEDICAL AID.
>> Translator: AFTER THE RUSSIAN
ATTACK ON UKRAINE, GERMANY
REVISED ITS DECADES-LONG
POSITION AND FOR THE FIRST TIME
SENT WEAPONS AND MILITARY GOODS
TO A WAR ZONE.
>> DOMESTICALLY, SCHULTZ IS
JUGGLING PRESSURE FROM MULTIPLE
SIDES OF HIS GOVERNMENT,
INCLUDING THOSE WHO WANT TO DO
LESS, NOT MORE FOR UKRAINE.
AND WHILE MANY APPLAUD THE MOVES
GERMANY HAS MADE UNDER THE
LEADERSHIP, OTHERS WISH THEY HAD
CO